[Music]
i
have a lot of artwork from childhood in
high school
that was saved by my parents and then
given to me because they want it out of
their house and some of its decent
quality
a lot of it is sentimental
but i want it out of my house
i
don't want to display it it doesn't
really serve anything for me at this
point in my life
and i mean i don't want it to go into
the trash but if it does i don't want to
know that it's being thrown away
so do you guys have any ideas of how i
can
get rid of it
places to give it to um just anything i
just made it out of my life at this
point
all right jeff so this is i obviously
had to bring it back into minimalism in
some way right and so what we're talking
about here is she's created some stuff
in the past that she may not be proud of
doesn't really want but also like she
wants it gone from her life it doesn't
want to get rid of it right that often
happens to many of us this reminds me
to some extent where someone was like i
want to eat meat but i don't want to
kill animals
and and yet so like i'll just pretend
that nothing is going so if someone else
can hide this art for me yeah i think
this is we all sort of have the residue
of our past right and it can haunt us
you even mentioned like oh there's some
things in this book that i i don't like
but you also recognize that this adds
value to people's lives and so in order
for it
to add value to people's lives there's
going to be things that you've created
in the past that
maybe you don't personally get value
from anymore but someone else might this
is more of a decluttering question
though hey i have a bunch of stuff from
the past
that i want to let go of and i'm
terrified of letting go of it should i
hold on to it for posterity or yeah uh
there's two things that come to mind one
is there's a little-known story about
hemingway when he moved to paris uh he
moved to paris because he was told that
that's where the most interesting people
in the world lived and he wanted to be a
writer and he
uh had had just um recovered from a
wound as an ambulance driver uh he
during world war one kind of drove over
this land mine and and got some uh
shrapnel in his leg
and um
and he got married moved paris uh it was
cheap there at the time uh it is not
cheap there anymore um no he moves to
paris and he's writing all the time he's
writing these stories and um
and his wife and he went on a trip
and she she came back from the trip to
meet him and he went back to paris
because he was working for a newspaper
at the time and he had this trunk
full of manuscripts like a couple of
books that he was working on and stories
and all kinds of things
and she lost the trunk
and or the trunk got lost and he blamed
her uh which she sold it on ebay
and
what's interesting about that is i mean
this is kind of interesting because
somewhere
or at some point there are these
uh undiscovered hemingway manuscripts
that nobody has ever found that you know
or i don't know they're buried somewhere
they got thrown away or whatever
um and what happened right after that is
he stepped into the most prolific season
of his life he wrote the sun also rises
shortly after that he wrote the sun also
rises in six weeks
and and and that was the book that put
him on the map
uh and made him basically an overnight
sensation and he eventually became
one of the 20th century's most famous
and successful authors
and you could say that it started out
with unintentional decluttering
and so i've got sort of two thoughts on
that one is if you really just want to
close your eyes and let go i think it's
okay to like have somebody take care of
that for you and go hey i don't want to
know about it yeah absolutely um and you
guys are the expert at this more than i
am um but i did just move
and i had 20 years of stuff um because
i'm a very sentimental person i had
letters i had things that i had written
things that people had written me
um going back 20 years and um
and i found it to be
very cathartic to actually go through
these letters uh one by one i mean
hundreds it took me hours and i didn't
like i like looked at you know looked at
them i didn't read all of them but some
of them i i got i i re-encountered the
memory of the experience of where i was
at that time who this person was to me
friend girlfriend parent you know lots
of different relationships
and um
i mean maybe three or four people it
it's sort of um i was like i still want
to be in touch with that person so i
took a picture of the letter and i
texted it to this person
as just sort of a way to like connect
with them and then i threw the letter
away because i was like this is what i
want i want the connection with the
human not the letter and then i actually
save just a handful of them because you
know they're nice mementos
and um
and that was that was a spiritual
experience i mean you guys know this um
and i wasn't i i wasn't ready for that
until
that point where it was significant to
me i was starting this new chapter of my
life and i kind of said goodbye
to these things while remembering the
memories and holding on to it i know
artwork can be a little bit different
but kind of i mean these were like songs
i'd written in some cases these were
paintings and drawings that i had or
that people had given me and i would say
you know if there's some stuff that you
want you want people to see cool like
maybe go hey friend
take care of this for me
and i do think it could be very
cathartic to go through some of that
stuff
and seth godin told me once when he
decluttered his library he said that his
books are his friends and he still
misses them every day and i as an author
i love that you know uh i
recently moved and i got rid of a lot of
stuff in like 10 books you know and the
other
9 000 remained
but your works of art are your friends
they're your family they're very
significant to you it's hard to throw
them away
and you can say goodbye to them in a
really beautiful way
um that isn't maybe as traumatic as you
know your wife showing up at a train
station without you know these these
staggering works of genius you've been
working on
and
it's
like it's okay to just go okay see you
later
i'm gonna let go of that energy so i can
go right the sun also rises yeah so i
can go i can be free of the energy
because a lot of work that we do early
early on is not good you know i don't
hear you saying this is really really
good stuff that needs to be in a museum
you have to have a lot of reps you've
got to do a lot of stuff and you can
give that stuff away or throw it away or
sell it it doesn't actually matter as an
artist you're trying to get to your best
work as quickly as possible and the best
way to do that is to do a lot of work
and not cling to each single piece of it
last night we were at the comedy store
and we saw this great comedian try a new
joke because i'm gonna try a new joke he
he he read the joke nobody laughed he
goes okay bad joke and this one woman
goes i don't get it he goes well here
let me explain it to you he goes if
nobody laughs though i don't need to
explain it it's dead
you know and you've got to be that
unprecious with your work yeah that's
him letting go and yeah so from a very
practical standpoint
if you need to save something for
posterity
i'm grateful like i know a lot of david
foster wallace's works are collected at
the university of texas at this sort of
but it's all catalogued digitally and i
don't need the actual physical artifact
if you have in fact it's better in many
respects to have the digital version
that way it's backed up
yeah anything like that and so if you
really feel like there's something i'd
like to hold on to for the sake of
archiving it for future generations fine
but the truth is we don't need to
archive most of our second grade artwork
well my mom or my my wife's mom did this
amazing thing for all of her kids you
know they collected a lot of sort of kid
stuff all throughout the the years as
parents often do but what she did in the
last year is she pared everything down
to one box per kid
here are the most sort of sentimental
memories and it created a boundary or a
barrier i can't go beyond this box but
then she handed each kid a very
intentional
box and here you go yeah and so if you
want an intentional way to do this
before it gets swept up in a flood or it
just someone else comes and steals it
from your house
doing that on your own curating it in a
way where it fits into a capsule of
sorts and then digitizing the other
things
but you're letting go so you can move
forward you can work on the future r
because if i continue to cling to the
books and the blog posts and everything
else that i wrote in the past is going
to prevent me from doing anything
meaningful going forward yeah art is an
expression of a moment and it's
wonderful to have a collection of some
moments but kids are incredibly prolific
you know what was interesting to me and
actually thought about you guys because
this just happened last week i was like
all right kids you know like stuff you
want to donate put in into this box
stuff that just needs to be trashed
because you know like the pieces aren't
you know all together whatever put it in
here and then stuff you want to keep put
it in here uh
my kids didn't have much stuff we've
been living in an apartment for the past
three years and they got rid of about
eighty percent of their stuff oh wow and
i was like
hey i gave this to you for christmas
and then yeah i don't use it anymore
that's awesome i was like no no no no
wait wait wait i'm like this cost some
money it was hard it was hard for me but
you know what's so interesting about
that is
kids are always in the moment they go
well that's from six months ago this is
what's true now and i had a lot of
artwork that my children had made and i
didn't keep all of it because some of it
kind of sucks sorry kids
and i would i would keep the stuff that
i really liked i'll go that was a cool
picture that i want to hold on to
because this is an articulation it's a
snapshot
of who my daughter was at five six years
old but think of it like this right
life is always happening and you could
take a picture of life happening right
and
one of my favorite spiritual teachers is
a guy named anthony demello
yeah he's my favorite and he talks about
he goes people go on trips to take
pictures of places they never saw
because you never you never got to slow
down and experience it yesterday we were
out here it's a drake line actually
that sounds right sounds right and it's
like that you know so much of life even
art is
holding on to moments that have already
passed now it's okay to take a picture
of a beautiful moment right like i'm
glad that i have some moments captured
but you could go through life taking
pictures of every moment and not
experiencing any of it same is true of
your art
i think it was bob dylan who said about
blowing in the wind he goes i don't even
know who wrote that
i'm not that guy anymore yes
my friend derek webb
who's a musician says when he plays his
old songs he plays them as covers
because he's not that person anymore
you know
and it's like a book it's like oh i
wrote that right gosh
that had to do with what i was reading
how i was sleeping what i was eating
what i was thinking i could never write
that book again that's right you know
and so your art is always an expression
of life
keep living and you will keep making
more art and if you want to hold on to
some stuff and share some stuff cool and
a lot of times the stuff that you think
is awesome people are like ah and some
of the stuff that you think is is okay
people love but keep living keep
creating and keep letting go of the
little articulations of moments that
you've manufactured because there will
be more moments and there will be more
art and most artists who are holding on
to relics of their past are afraid that
they're done and that their best work is
behind them and that is only ever true
when you believe it's true
yeah we cling out of out of fear
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com slash the minimalists
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free